previously known for starring in FX's
hit Atlanta sassy beats was as surprised
as anyone when she landed the role of
super lucky mutant Domino in Deadpool 2
USA Today called her a captivating
standouts and Vanity Fair proclaimed her
the best thing about the r-rated sequel
she slipped into the role like she was
born to play it but getting to that
point required a lot of work here's how
beats got ripped for Deadpool - I'm not
one to Jim a first time for everything
beats never had to work out for her
roles in 2017 SGO storm or Atlanta
either but when she signed on to play
Domino she knew it was going to require
her to hit the gym she told The
Hollywood Reporter in my routine
day-to-day I didn't really work out that
much so it was a huge transition
emotionally and physically I'd never
really brought myself out far and she
revealed it wasn't just physically
exhausting telling shadow and out the
training ends up becoming this mental
and emotional experience as well putting
in the time beats trained four hours a
day for months to get into shape before
filming began she told I be T I'm going
to be shooting guns I fight and a lot of
that movement is full-body and physical
he's doing that for 12 hours a day and
they just want you to have the stamina
reflecting on the fatal onset out to the
nth of a stunt woman joy Harris beats
also revealed that leading man Ryan
Reynolds helped us stay focused telling
Entertainment Tonight it's amazing kind
of watching Ryan do you think he's
genuinely incredibly talented trainer to
the stars
you might not know Don Saladino by name
but you've definitely seen his work
dubbed the superhero trainer Saladin OHS
client list includes Marvel star
Scarlett Johansson and Sebastian Stan
and Wolverines Hugh Jackman he's also
trained Ryan Reynolds and his wife Blake
Lively Saladino began training Reynolds
for Deadpool 2 in February 2017 which
was how he became acquainted with beats
who admitted that she loved working with
Saladino and her feeling was very much
mutual becoming a superhero after
Deadpool to hit theaters Saladino
revealed to PopSugar that his first saw
in training feats was we had to turn her
into more of an ass kicker Saladino
admitted that the style of training he
recommended for beats can intimidate
female clients but he said picking up
things like kettlebells and doing things
like squats
split squats it's the stuff that works
the best it's elevates the heart rate
the most and it's not linear and so
one-dimensional like how most people
train eating a vegan diet because beats
his vegan her diet didn't really change
all that much during a Deadpool 2
training but she told shadow and act you
have to change how you eat and it also
takes away your energy doing that
alongside shooting and prepping and all
that stuff it's a lot of work but it was
also really cool crushing it
playing Domino left its mark on beats
quite literally
she told USA Today that she has a scar
on her chest from a stray shell that hit
her during a shootout scene she also
passed out from exhaustion in a leather
body suit in the middle of a fight
sequence but despite it all she says it
was absolutely worth it she told RTE we
had been working so much and I was
thinking hopefully it'll look good and I
remember doing the first take and then
seeing the playback and I was like it's
amazing thanks for watching click the
loop icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love today
[Music]